information is still being gathered
about the situation in france as this
becomes more and more clearer the prime
minister chaired the emergency cobra
meeting last night and then spoke to the
president of france
i'm glad that president macron indicated
his determination to stop the vile
people smuggling gangs and importantly
to work with work closely with all
partners across europe i have literally
madame deputy speaker just spoken again
with my french counterpart minister
domin and i've once again reached out
and made my offer very clear
to france in terms of joint france and
uk cooperation
joint patrols to prevent these dangerous
journeys from taking place i've offered
to work with france to put more offices
on the ground and do absolutely whatever
is necessary to secure the area so that
vulnerable people do not risk their
lives by getting into unsee-worthy boats
madam deputy speaker there is a global
immigration illegal migration crisis
as i've stated many times
these journeys across the channel are
absolutely unnecessary
but i as also as i have been warning for
two years they are also lethally
dangerous
what happened yesterday was a dreadful
shock it was not a surprise but it is
also a reminder of how vulnerable people
are
put at peril when in the hands of
criminal gangs
there is also madame deputy speaker no
quick fix
this is about addressing long-term pull
factors smashing the criminal gangs that
treat human beings as cargo and tackling
supply chains
this requires coordinated international
effort and i've been in constant contact
with my counterparts from france poland
austria belgium
italy and greece to name just a few
because of the nature of the crisis and
the fact that we are seeing 80 million
displaced people in the world this was
of course madame deputy speaker a major
theme of discussion at the g7 interior
ministers back in september
we're also seeing it play out on several
land borders in europe and in the
mediterranean sea
and given the chance the traffickers
will always find people to exploit and
manipulate some of them do not even know
that they are coming to the uk
this does mean tackling issues upstream
and not waiting until people have
reached eu countries and i've always
been extremely clear that i want to
cooperate and am cooperating with
international colleagues
the united kingdom has given its
unflinching and generous support to
france to end this terrible trade in
people smuggling
we are not working just to end end these
crossings because we don't care and
we're heartless the united kingdom has a
clear and a generous humane approach to
asylum seekers and refugees
yes people should come here legally and
the system must be fair but the main
issue is this crossing the channel in
small boats is extremely dangerous and
yesterday was the moment that many of us
had feared for many years the criminals
that facilitate these journeys are
motivated by self-interest and profit
not by compassion
they threaten intimidate bully and
assault the people who get into these
bows and they have a complete absolute
disregard for human right
they use the money they make for other
heinous crimes and we simply have to
break their business model and of course
bring them to justice
the government's new plan for
immigration which will be put into law
through the nationality borders bill is
a longer-term solution that will address
many of these underlying factors to
deterring illegal migration and
addressing underlying import factors
into the uk's asylum system
it will bring in a range of measures
including the one-stop appeals process
the ability to process claims outside
the country the ability to declare
inadmissibility to our asylum system and
have differentiation those who arrive in
the uk having passed through safe
countries and lives and life sentences
for people smugglers
people should madam deputy speaker claim
asylum in the first safe country they
reach and nobody needs to be
nobody needs to flee france in order to
be safe
however madam deputy speaker we are not
waiting until the national team borders
bill passes we are undertaking a wide
range of operational and diplomatic work
i have already approved maritime tactics
including boat turnarounds for border
force to deploy
the government the police the national
crime agency are taking action at every
level to take down the people smuggling
gangs and once again however we cannot
do it alone
we continue to work closely with the
french prevent crossings more than 20
000 have been stopped this year which i
think all members of this house should
recognize the magnitude and the scale of
the illegal migration crisis that we are
seeing
we have dismantled 17 organized criminal
groups
and secured over 400 arrests and 65
convictions
but this crisis continues clearly
demonstrating we need to do more
together this is a complicated issue and
there is no simple fix it does mean a
herculean effort and it will be
impossible without close cooperation
between all international partners and
agencies
i also urge colleagues to reconsider
their opposition to the national indian
borders bill
because it is an essential element in
finding a long-term solution to what is
madame deputy speaker a long-term
problem that successive governments have
faced over decades
as we mourn those who have died in the
most horrendous of circumstances
i hope that the whole house can come
together
to send a clear message
that crossing the channel in this lethal
way in a small boat is not the way to
come to our country
it is of course unnecessary illegal
and desperately unsafe i commend this
statement